The Joe Rogan experience. Let's let's, uh, establish your position, Alex, on,
on, on COVID. What is your position on that?
Sure. So people accuse me of being a COVID denialist or I, you know,
I don't think it's real. I don't think anyone dies from it.
That's that's all nonsense. Joe COVID is real. It, uh, you know,
it emerged from, we can talk about where it might have emerged from, uh,
earlier this year, maybe in late 2019, it's killed a lot of people. Um,
it's contagious. And, uh, and, and, you know, it's been a problem this year.
It's been a significant problem. Yeah.
It is not worthy of the response that we have had to it.
I believe lockdowns have been a mistake and we can go into all of it, but,
but we have overreacted in an extremely dangerous way this year.
I believe we've overreacted as well. And I think that in particular,
one of the things that disturbs me the most is that there has been no accounting
for the damage that has been done by forcing people to shut down their
businesses. And they're only,
the only thought has been making sure that the ICU
beds are open and that, you know,
somehow or another people are able to get treatment for this.
There's been I've openly criticized.
The fact there's been no discussion whatsoever about getting healthy like this.
None.
No one's encouraging you because they're worried about being called a fat shamer
or some other nonsensical term.
I mean, I think it's much worse than that, because if,
if you remember back in may or may back in March, we were told 15 days,
15 days to slow the spread. Let's not have the hospitals be overrun.
And at some point maybe it was in April. Maybe it was in may.
Somehow this became no one can ever get sick and die from COVID.
It is wrong that this disease exists and we have to do everything to stop it,
no matter what the consequences.
And you mentioned businesses business that are important, but to me,
what's even more important is what we're doing to our kids.
What we've done with school closures, what we've done with normalizing,
the idea that being outside with your friends is dangerous. We are, we are,
we are screwing over our kids in the worst part.
Well, I think we had an idea of what COVID was going to be.
I know I certainly did for the first few weeks, I was like,
this is going to kill everybody.
I thought I was going to kill a 10% of the population.
I was really worried about it. Yeah.
I remember being in the supermarket stocking up and thinking Jesus Christ like
this, this feels so crazy.
But I also remember thinking it was going to last two weeks. Yep.
And now here we are still reacting this way.
We're now deep in a January or deep into December, almost in a January. Yep. Um,
a lot of my friends were caught including young Jamie over here and Jamie beat
it in a day. Uh, Tony Hinchcliffe has it now.
He was sick yesterday and today feels good.
And this is the case with so many people. Whereas if they got the flu, I knew,
I know a lot of the same people that have got the flu.
They were knocked down into the dirt for three or four days, maybe a week,
maybe two weeks. Um, it's different than we thought was going to be,
but we're still reacting. Like it was the same thing. And then there's this,
this fear porn that everybody likes to pedal.
It's this weird thing where everybody wants to think that, you know,
if you catch it, you have a 10% chance of dying or the sky is falling. And.
It's just, it's weird.
How, uh, people want to pretend that it's still what it used to be.
And they want to say, you know, you should think about this.
Cause 300,000 Americans have died and you want to go stop. No,
300,000 Americans have died from COVID.
That also had a lot of other stuff.
How many people have died just from COVID and it's a relatively small number in
comparison. It's like a bad flu year.
All right. Um, so it's complicated. Here's, here's the thing. And, and, um,
and I don't know if you, if you, and you know, this is,
as I said about all this stuff for you, but the, the booklets, I,
especially the first one, which is about ha uh, death, counting how we go,
how we count a COVID death, go. I go into this in detail. Okay. Well,
let's talk about that right away. So, okay. There's,
here's the most fundamental fact about COVID that the media doesn't report
accurately, how stratified the risk is by age. So you mentioned,
you mentioned, you know, people who are, who are,
might be overweight or have diabetes, all that stuff does add to your risk.
What really adds to your risk is age and people and people don't really,
I think this is true of almost everybody.
People don't really have a good idea of what, what risk is. Right. So if I say,
you know, like it's riskier to be old and have COVID than to be young,
you might think, okay, it's like two to one or three to one or five to one,
it's kind of like normal risks.
Like what are the odds that the jets are going to beat the Rams, like one in 10,
you know, last week. And that happened, the jets beat the Rams. Um,
this risk is not like that.
It's like somewhere between 110,000 times,
the risk of in what age.
So maybe 75 versus 25,
80 versus 25. If you look at who dies from this,
it is overwhelmingly people over 65,
75, 85. Okay. The, uh, the median age of death in,
in European countries,
or which are a little bit healthier than the U S is in the low eighties.
But that doesn't really tell you the real risk,
because what you need to understand is that only two or 3% of the population is
over 82 or 83.
Now what about people? Like there was that guy, who's a Broadway actor.
So it was a young, healthy looking guy who got sick and wound up dying from it.
So th that's going to happen. So there's two issues. First of all,
that happens to people with the flu. I can point you to stories from 2018, what,
you know, young, healthy teacher dies of the flu.
It just was never reported nationally this way, right? That's a, B is,
if you look at those cases,
oftentimes there's weird idiosyncratic stuff happening of which the number one
thing is a lot of those people were put on ventilators very early.
You're put on ventilators and they never came off.
We're not having that as much anymore. And if you look,
the average age of death is actually creeping up. Now, it looks like, and okay,
so that's one, is that the risk?
We talk about that. Yes. The ventilators. Yep. So what happened.
What happened was in March, especially back when everybody was terrified,
there's there, there there's something called a nebulizing procedure.
So there are procedures that re that we're inserting tubes into people,
and it releases a lot of, um, you know, aerosols from them.
And the fear was this is going to get aerosolized and the nurses and the doctors
are all going to get sick and die.
And we're going to have no medical staff ventilator avoids that problem. Okay.
So the F the feeling was let's ventilate very early.
This is a really serious disease. Let's get everybody we can on ventilators.
That's when, remember when we needed a hundred thousand ventilators,
200,000 ventilators, that was the idea, okay,
we're going to ventilate really early. It turns out that was a terrible idea.
It turns out that as, as Elon Musk likes to say, you know, your lungs,
if you, if you ventilate too early, it's just like a meat bellows,
and you can blow out people's lungs if you over ventilate.
And it looks like that happened. I will tell you not that we're not,
not that we don't use ventilators for COVID, but right now in the United States,
I believe there were about 8,000 people on ventilators. Can I.
Can I stop you for a second meet bellows, like bellows, like fireplace bellows,
right?
So you're just finishing this Erin and you're. And like,
if you push it in a pressure, that's too high,
you can just blow out people's lungs.
So you re literally destroy their lungs.
Yes, yes. We did that with people and, and, and it became clear.
It became pretty clear, pretty early on. And,
and they S and they tried to stop doing it, and they have stopped doing it.
You know.
That's why they were saying that 80% of the people they put on ventilators wound
up dying.
It's not just that they were so sick by the time they got to ventilators,
they were dying. That's right. And they couldn't save them.
It was just that the ventilators themselves.
Did damage. That's wow. That,
and I don't think that actually too many people would argue that even in
hospitals, I can point you to stories that have been written about this.
And I can point you to sort of in-hospital discussion of this. Um, again,
there is a role for ventilators,
for people who really cannot breathe on their own,
but this early ventilation that we,
that we used back in March and April killed people,
and some of the people killed our people who were younger,
who probably would have survived.
My friend, Michael yo was young when he got it. And he was really beaten down.
He did a lot of traveling. He flew to New York, he did morning radio.
The whole deal flew back, drove to Vegas, visited his family,
and then drove home that night and then did a bunch of auditions in LA and then
got sick, real sick. His doctor didn't put him on a ventilator because he said,
if I put you on a ventilator,
your lung is going to stop working and you're going to die.
And he's okay today because of that. But he's a young,
healthy, robust guy. And he got it and almost died. I mean, he was really,
really sick for about two weeks.
So, but he recovered. Right. So again, we're not saying this disease,
isn't real. And we're not saying that some people, unfortunately,
aren't going to have these bad reactions to it, but, but you know,
back in March, maybe he gets put on a ventilator and maybe he dies. Well,
he got it very, very early. So that was so his, so he was fortunate.
He had a doctor who was smart.
Yeah. Catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free,
only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.